énorme performance de jeu de QI dans les Marines
mais elle a abandonné la drogue petit crime nous
n'avons jamais eu de travail est-ce que
votre père m'a sauvé la vie c'est
votre beau gars les garçons j'ai eu une
journée plutôt émouvante alors quel que soit votre boeuf avec
eggy est et je '  Je suis sûr que c'est bien fondé
J'apprécierais que vous
nous laissiez tranquilles
Que voyez-vous Je vois que c'est potentiel
Kingsman est une
agence de renseignement internationale opérant au
plus haut niveau de discrétion si vous êtes
prêt à vous adapter vous pouvez transformer  dans
un espion intéressé ah oui vous êtes sur le point de vous
lancer dans l'entretien d'embauche le plus dangereux
du monde nous sommes là pour
vous tester pour limiter pour améliorer vos compétences
entraînez-vous du mal là-bas
si vous obtenez du sang sur le tapis, vous devez
prendre  le tapis levé ne supporte pas la
vue du sang Colleen et Taryn merci
beaucoup d'être avec moi aujourd'hui à
Paris pour ce film Kings mang je l'aime tellement
il est tellement drôle vraiment tout d'abord
Colleen on s'est rencontrés il y a quelques
mois  il y a un film très Woody Allen
oui avec Emma c'est vrai
avez-vous une préférence entre Emma et
n-terminal pour faire la promotion c'est
plus facile avec Tara no Hema Hema est un
peu plus convenable à part qu'ils
sont presque impossibles à distinguer ce qui
était  votre première réaction à tous les deux je veux
dire quand vous lisez juste garder pour les
Kinsmen pour la première fois je veux dire qu'il
vous faudrait Wow un tel cadeau quand j'ai
lu le script
Kingsman pour la première fois j'avais déjà
parlé à Matthew Vaughn  pendant
près d'un an oui donc je n'ai pas
commencé avec le script j'ai commencé avec la
conversation il n'y avait pas de script je
n'en savais rien et il
m'a montré la bande dessinée donc j'avais ça en
fait je pensais oui je pensais  c'était
probablement une aventure extraordinaire
quelque chose de nouveau mais vous savez cette période de
la vie et votre tour
pour moi c'était en quelque sorte représentatif d'
une opportunité de carrière incroyable vraiment
donc j'étais juste excité de travailler avec
Matthew Colin Michael le fait que le
script était si  bon vient de rendre le
tout plus excitant Je ne pense pas que ce soit
un secret que je n'avais jamais fait de film
auparavant, alors pour me lancer dans le cinéma et ma
première expérience, c'est un film que je veux
dire, je pense personnellement que c'est fabuleux, je
pense que c'est tellement  beaucoup de plaisir tu sais j'espère j'espère
certainement donc je n'ai jamais rencontré de
tailleur avant je sais que tu n'en es pas un venez
avec moi que voyez-vous je
vois un jeune homme avec du
potentiel qu'est-ce que c'est l'électrique Yuya
ne sois pas ridicule  c'est une grenade à main
taisez-vous et c'est parfois si difficile
de décrire ce film parce que ça pourrait
être vous savez une sorte de match de James
Bond mais ce n'est pas vraiment que ça pourrait
être un film d'aventure comme je l'ai dit
film d'agent secret très chic très intelligent
pensez-vous au James Bond bien sûr bien sûr au
James Bond ça ne
résume pas précisément ce que c'est comme vous le dites
mais je pense que Matthew Vaughn commence
à s'imposer comme un presque un
genre à lui tout seul vous savez je pense qu'il
y a  y a certains réalisateurs qui
s'affirment tellement sur leur propre style mais
en fait ils deviennent la référence
tu sais c'est si c'est un pastiche de
ceci ou ça s'en sert au
final je pense que les gens
commencent déjà à en parler
c'est un Matthew Vaughn  genre de film et
je pense que c'est la meilleure façon même
s'il est très diversifié, mais il
joue avec des points de référence très très familiers
tu as raison ouais tu sais nous avons
frappé Stardust c'est un peu de la fantaisie un
peu de la science-fiction un peu  un peu une
sorte de conte de fées vintage vous savez
gâteau en couches c'est les gangsters avec la
culture pop kick-ass Tarantino l'espace est
très il y a un peu juste il y a
quelque chose de Tarantino mais je pense que l'
humour est différent et la sensibilité
est pour moi plus légère c'est plus  ludique
Tarantino est ludique aussi mais je trouve un
film plus sombre parfois un peu trop Tarantino c'est comme si j'avais ici
n'est-ce pas je pense que oui et je pense que
vous savez que l'utilisation de la violence est
différente des manières de le faire mec
savez-vous ce que ça  signifie
et laissez-moi vous donner une leçon que vous pourriez
presque imaginer pendant les combats que
ces bulles qui disent pouvoir et
vous disent ouais gisaient comme une bande dessinée oui
très
absent et coup de pied était comme une bande dessinée
et donc je pense qu'il prend très très
matériel familier le matériel
avec lequel nous avons grandi que nous avons aimé qu'il
aime et lui c'est un hommage affectueux
mais en même temps il s'en moque
faire ces
films comme Jason Bourne rencontre James mana
peut-être pourriez-vous dire cela mais je pense que
ce serait le joyau du James Bond d'
autrefois vous savez que ce n'est certainement
pas Daniel Craig rencontre Matt Damon je
pense qu'il a trop euh je franchement je
pense  il y a trop de comédie pour
la capacité de cette équipe Carly, nous avons aussi un peu de
camp ouais tu sais quand tu vois
Harry dire que j'ai eu une journée plutôt émouvante
et quand tu vois eggy tu sais
vers la fin du film dans  son costume il
y a un peu d'infirmière de camp que
nous campons tous les deux un peu
pour couper pour la valeur de la comédie vous voyez le
film Trading Places mm-hmm que diriez-vous de
Nikita
jolie femme d'accord mon point est que
le manque d'un  la cuillère en argent vous a mis
sur un certain chemin mais vous n'avez pas besoin de rester
sur celui-ci si vous êtes prêt à vous adapter et à
apprendre que vous pouvez transformer vous savez comme dans
ma belle dame
vous pourriez Leon filet surprend oui comme
ma belle dame seulement dans ce cas  Je
vous offre l'opportunité de devenir un
Kingsman un tailleur un agent Kingsman comme
un espion et des épées intéressés vous pensez que
j'ai quelque chose à perdre certains des
films d'action d'aujourd'hui vont très
résolument dans le sens de
lourds et  s'attaquer sérieusement aux
problèmes émotionnels du personnage vous
savez que nous avons des super-héros avec une âme et
une enfance malheureuse vous savez avec leurs
propres tourments personnels j'aime personnellement
tout ça mais un ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
que cela remonte à quand c'était
juste  amusant je vous ne savez pas sur mon
personnage vous ne savez rien bien rien
ouais vous savez qu'il a juste ces
compétences et il s'occupe des garçons
c'est tout ce dont vous avez besoin de savoir qu'il
est malade
nous sommes une
agence de renseignement internationale indépendante opérant au
plus haut niveau de discrétion,
les agents Kingsmen sont les nouveaux chevaliers
parce que Colleen joue votre martyr et
ce film pendant le tournage était la
même chose
à l'inverse faites-le comme votre moniteur faisant
God's by Kali à certains égards en vertu
du fait que Colleen est un acteur
avec  beaucoup plus d'expérience que moi que je
connais même une fois en fait
Colleen est vous connaissez l'un des
acteurs les plus célèbres du monde et personne ne sait
qui je suis mais si vous pouviez imaginer une
relation entre deux personnes sur un plateau
quelqu'un avec une grande quantité d'expérience
et quelqu'un qui n'est jamais là auparavant pour
quelqu'un qui a la plus grande expérience
pour donner des conseils
non sollicités s'est senti désolé pour le garçon avez-
vous trouvé cela humiliant, il est
autant matériel Kingsman que n'importe lequel d'entre eux,
nous sommes ici pour améliorer votre test de compétences
vous aux limites nous devons résoudre des problèmes
sous pression comme quoi faire quand l'un
de votre groupe n'a pas de parachute ce que
Collin a fait était de me donner c'était
assez ouvert avec moi pour que nous
puissions construire une amitié ce que j'ai fait
c'est un  beaucoup de votre travail et pensez comment
fait-il cela, je pense que vous
appelleriez probablement cela une bromance mais peut-être que la chose la plus
importante pour vous faites ce
traitement était d'agir et de réagir je veux dire quand
vous avez la séquence
je cuisine leurs pensées je  signifie que c'est tout c'est
tout ce qui est toujours important c'est de
réagir tu sais que réagir serait
mieux pour ça que d'agir vraiment tu
sais c'est c'est d'agir c'est c'est c'est
deux personnes dans une scène avec un dialogue
entre deux personnes ce que fait l'autre personne
est beaucoup plus important  que ce que
vous faites et moi, j'ai vraiment senti
que tout s'est passé assez naturellement
entre moi et Colleen, alors oui, nous nous sommes
amusés, Fred s'est amusé bizarrement et
c'est la chose la plus importante que vous savez que
certains d'entre vous auront apprise la nuit dernière, le
travail d'équipe est primordial  ici à Kingsman,
nous sommes ici pour améliorer vos compétences,
vous tester pour limiter, c'est pourquoi vous allez
choisir un chiot
quoi que vous alliez, votre chien va vous en prendre
soin, vous lui apprendrez, rappelez-vous
le temps qu'il est complètement formé,
vous aussi  soyez ceux d'entre vous qui sont toujours là, c'est-à-dire que
vous comprenez
choisir votre chiot le caniche quelle est la
race de travail la plus ancienne de leurs chiens de chasse, il est facile
d'entraîner le
carlin voir Bulldog dedans,
il sera compris quand il chut et
c'est souvent je veux dire voir ça  film pour
moi le plus important prend l'humour de
l'autre de ce film c'était aussi
nécessaire pour toi pendant le tournage
on t'a rencontré travaillant tout le temps cet
humour aussi pour garder l'équilibre tu sais
entre tous les différents boulot car
oui nous  ouais eh bien, je pense que l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles Matthew est si doué dans
ce qu'il fait et la raison pour laquelle il le fait avec
tant de succès, c'est parce qu'il
n'a pas un mélange très bien réglé d'un
technicien cinématographique sophistiqué un homme
avec une vision mature  il sait que vous
savez qu'il est très mondain et il sait comment
ces choses sont réalisées et il
a également beaucoup accès à lui-même à 12
ans et au gars qui sait ce qu'il
voudrait voir à l'écran,
c'est le fan c'est le gars  dans le
public et cette partie de lui est
très vivante et c'est pourquoi cela fonctionne si
bien
son oreille est très bien il est extraordinairement
bien accordé même en ce qui concerne la façon de
livrer une ligne vous savez qu'il le dira
très simplement faites ceci  les fabricants d'appartements
ou celui-ci peut chanter spécial ouais reprendre
comme une chanson peut-être presque comme
marquer quelque chose que vous savez à mon époque est
un acteur qui est très court Je
travaille professionnellement depuis environ deux
ans et demi Matthew est la personne la plus
instinctive  J'ai déjà travaillé avec
je pense et je vous laisse lui faire confiance
parce que c'est exactement le point sur lequel vous me faites
confiance il y a des réalisateurs qui ont des
instincts mais ce sont de mauvais instincts et
ainsi de suite quand votre instinct est alors de se
demander si c'est oh  mon dieu
écoute on y va encore
quand Matthew le dit je sais qu'il a
raison il a raison parce qu'il entend
quelque chose dans sa tête pour le film
[Musique]
oh oui très très sympa
on va avoir besoin d'une paire de chaussures pour
aller avec ta  convenir
à un Oxford est n'importe quelle chaussure formelle avec
laçage ouvert cette pièce décorative supplémentaire
s'appelle broguing oh ce n'est pas cassé
des mots pour vivre par des mots d'œufs pour vivre en
essayant une paire ce qui est aussi intéressant, c'est
qu'il y a eu un jour où nous avons passé
très très longtemps  temps
sur une ligne de dialogue juste une ligne
cette ligne prête ce que nous trouverons un
bon ce n'était pas juste une livraison c'était il
était blanc peut-être que tu devrais être assis
ici et peut-être non ne prenons pas un verre
ou peut-être devrions-nous  prendre un verre et j'ai
pu voir ce qu'il cherchait
parce qu'il y avait un tableau dans son esprit
il y avait quelque chose qui se préparait et j'étais
inquiet parce que j'avais deux pages de
dialogue à faire plus tard et je pensais que
nous n'allions jamais  faites-le et puis avec
les deux pages nous l'avons fait en 20 minutes
ouais si Colin et moi marchions sur le plateau et
quelque chose à propos de dire que vous savez
esthétiquement ce ver set n'était pas à
mon goût s'il n'y en avait pas donc il y
avait quelque chose à ce sujet qui  ne correspondait pas à
sa vision nous n'avons pas tourné vous savez que c'est
une douleur terrible pour tout le monde rien n'a
dit que c'est très bon pour le film
mais c'est très bon comme vous l'étiez c'est
génial dans un film je veux dire parfois c'est une
sorte de film la lumière  n'est pas très bon
le cadre est éclairé et celui-ci est
incroyable je vois que c'est ce en quoi je fais confiance et
puis ce n'est pas vous savez je ne veux pas
être simpliste à ce sujet parce que ces
choses coûtent de l'argent aussi vous savez la plupart des
films que nous ne faisons pas '  Vous n'avez vraiment pas,
vous ne pouvez pas payer le temps supplémentaire pour
réparer ces choses, mais néanmoins c'est
merveilleux d'être entre les mains de quelqu'un
qui est poussé à ce degré de
perfection et c'est très alarmant
d'être dans le  les mains de quelqu'un disent non,
c'est bien, vous savez que vos scores d'armes
sont excellents au fait que
vous les connaissez et c'est
notre pistolet standard, il est assez
unique car vous verrez qu'il tire également une
cartouche de fusil de chasse pour une utilisation en
désordre.  diverses situations comment se sentent-ils qu'ils
sont bons maintenant faites de votre mieux pour
imiter un salut formel d'aristocrates allemands
maintenant sortez c'est malade c'est intéressant
parce que votre personnage dans ce film je l'
aime tellement au début est comme
un adolescent et il grandit  essayez de grandir ce
n'est pas un message sur le oh c'est
difficile d'être un adulte bien sûr mais
votre personnage a grandi dans le même
sens, alors je pense que m'asseoir
ici et vous dire que j'ai grandi
serait farfelu je suis moi  je pense que je
travaille toujours des progrès c'est un travail c'était
tout à fait correct collège merci car le travail
progresse et mais indéniablement vous le savez
vous savez au Royaume-Uni nous dirions d'un
baptême du feu je ne sais pas si vous êtes
familier  avec cette phrase,
vous savez, apprendre à travers un extrait une
expérience incroyablement extrême, j'ai dû
grandir rapidement à certains égards, en
partie grâce à la réalisation du film
et à sa promotion, il y a
beaucoup de responsabilités là-bas, donc il y en
a là  y en a-t-il tous des Munim ou
ils sont assez simplistes mais il y a
des parallèles entre le voyage de X et
le mien je suppose que je ne tue personne
qui est désolé pour le garçon est-ce
qu'il est autant de matériel Kingsman que n'importe lequel d'entre
eux plus donc j'ai eu un dîner  rendez-vous avec
rapidité l'humanité est le virus et je suis
le remède on dirait que beaucoup de gens
vont mourir maintenant on dirait que je
te donne pas
fils de [ __ ] Karine c'est toujours un
grand plaisir de te rencontrer peut-être deux
trois quatre cinq  fois je t'ai rencontré pendant
deux ou trois ans de bonnes choses et Alex
tellement à chaque fois un projet différent
avec un réalisateur différent comment tu
essaies de trouver un bon scénario je veux dire tu
reçois beaucoup de sommeil en ce moment et tu
as beaucoup de choix c'est  jamais un choix pur et
parfait parce que je suppose que je ne
sais pas à quoi cela ressemblerait mais je
suppose que les gens pourraient imaginer que le choix
est de cinq scripts et ils ont tous un
financement ils ont tous une date de début et
ils ont tous un réalisateur et ils
ont tous  casting et tout ce que vous avez à faire est de
choisir ce n'est jamais comme ça vous savez
celui-ci n'a pas d'argent
réalisateur ce beau scénariste
je ne suis pas sûr celui-là j'aime le
réalisateur mais le scénario a besoin de beaucoup de
travail et ils n'ont pas  son casting et
ils n'ont pas de début donc vous
jouez toujours avec maintenant c'est de la chance ce n'est
jamais un scientifique quand il n'y a pas de règles et vous voulez
dire non il n'y en a pas donc vous travaillez
avec des inconnues et des variables incroyables
et il y en a tellement  raisons pour lesquelles
quelque chose est attrayant et tant de
raisons différentes pour lesquelles quelque chose vous rend
prudent vous savez que je filme je viens de
terminer ça s'appelle le génie c'était l'
un des rares scripts que j'ai jamais lu
et j'ai pensé que c'est un script que je
veux  à faire je ne veux pas changer je
commence la semaine prochaine ben y'a pas d'
argent et y'a pas de réalisateur et mais
tu aimes les fin d'histoire sont parfaites c'était il y a
cinq ans
et je l'ai tourné juste avant Noël
c'est le temps que ça a pris ouais le  le processus
est que les rangas allaient et venaient les réalisateurs ne pouvez-
vous pas savoir et ouais pour que ce soit comme ça
celui-ci je voulais travailler avec
Matthew Vaughn j'étais à peu près sûr
qu'il allait commencer l'année prochaine
à la place c'était l'année d'après et  ils
n'étaient toujours pas de script, donc je suis c'est une
description très tortueuse de la façon dont c'est,
mais je suppose que même lorsque vous êtes dans une
position incroyablement chanceuse, les
choses sur lesquelles vous devez baser vos décisions
ne sont pas très précises.
si spécial, remettez-le
[Musique]
merci beaucoup a - merci beaucoup
et merci pour le film de frein taxi
beaucoup merci merci tourner écœurant
[Musique]